das herausfahren bisher ist glaube dass
man eben teilweise in gebiete kommt wo
ein normaler pilot und anführungszeichen
nicht hinkommt wir sind viel im tiefflug
unterwegs zb oder ich schieße in der art
und weise unterwegs
bei wetterverhältnissen zur normalen
nicht mehr fliegen würde wo wir aber
noch für einen türken und aufregen
können
natürlich geht es danach teilweise für
die bevölkerung für österreicher sein
können und das macht sich bezahlt
eine der größten ausstellungen und eine
der coolsten jobs zu machen die sind im
land gibt und dann auch noch zu wissen
dass man an jedem einzelnen tag und wir
österreich im einsatz ist das ist etwas
was man sich damit nicht erfüllt sondern
nachmittag barkeit aber abzuwägen ist
abgelaufen
[Musik]